code possible so gently beautiful okay
escape with the meteor how bad could it
be run away from the beach we don't have
a lot of time kiddies we got a sin
husband kill him don't bang no don't
shove your butt into his face that's the
opposite of what you want you like this
honey
you let you cheat on me well look what I
do with my own leg butt slam ow I think
I broke my coccyx I'm the winner here
I'm the real winner
no I kissed your forehead how're you
drinking that how about you drink some
of honey is this why you left me
[Music]
fruity neon ball throw because I'm so
good at handling Oh
Oh actually one and nothing bad happened
Oh kalmyk kalmyk kalmyk gum
use me oh wait what holy crap it's got a
lot more serious than I had a really no
time for that dad we gotta go whoa whoa
whoa
colorful challenge how colorful and how
challenge I can't face it
whoa that wasn't that hard
that's what that's what she said
oh so gently slowly oh come on my spine
Oh dangling by my intestines this is
actually quite difficult I must say I
made it I made it I got a little little
too excited there Oh what happened
behind the scenes there Oh screw it I'm
going in the pit all right I'll play by
your rules geez yes - dingus ha pogo
jump so excited come on oh wait no come
on now I don't think we're but this time
Oh mark now uh how much do you want to
pay for this alright kiddies we're gonna
go visit the Easter Bunny in candy land
where there's nothing but sunshine and
magical rainbow where you guys can no no
stop freezin on me oh goodness
I'm so sorry dad I'm sorry
hey no
[Music]
[Applause]
oh not kill I kill sell I don't kill
yourself one more time
never mind everybody do the dinosaur
which involves mashing people's bodies
into bloody bloody bits ripping off
heads and taking them with me then
shoving their swords up their ass then
going into the winner's circle and then
I'm gonna stop singing now eros dancing
oh he didn't suspect a thing lamest
assassin ever
[Music]
all right goodies let's try this one
more time don't die this time
[Music]
Oh get out there come on get out there
gonna be bad news
goodness braving battle one killers oh
don't mind me everybody
that's walking along this way
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you liked the
video and want to see more why not
subscribe today want to help the channel
grow leave a like
add it to your favorites or share with
your friends on Facebook and Twitter
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
hey hey buddy ever just ever just look
up at the stars and just wonder what's
what's out there what's out there man
whoo
what's up above all that junk you know
what I mean you know what I mean you
know what I mean man man you know I mean
I just wonder like if out of all those
stars if were like alone in the universe
oh man I totally feel the same way
sometimes I just look up and I I just
stare at the stars meet you man me too
hey hey you ever wonder like if if like
humans you ever think that we all see
different colors but we all just call
them different names whoa you just
totally blew my mind man well what is
that oh you just blew my mind dude so
glad I didn't kill you bruh
I was about to who's about to do a sweet
movie see that sword up there see that
sword yeah man I see that sword let's
just kill you with it but they're not
get in
oh man that's totally like life man you
make choices and choices affect each
other's lives
dude you just blew my freaking mind Wow
huh like what am I even gonna do now I
don't even know man I don't even know
dude you just got to keep living life
just got to keep moving forward one day
at a time because whatever you do no
matter how insignificant you feel the
earth still goes around the Sun Wow dude
stop blowing the mind man
stop blowing the mind dude dude I can't
even Wow dude you freaking know